Well, good morning again, church.
It's great to see you.
Uh, if you're new to our church, we're thankful
that you would choose to be with us.
Uh, we'd love to get to know you, help you connect
with the Lord, and connect with our church if possible.
And so you just head out to the new here area in the lobby.
Uh, there's someone out there to greet you and,
and to get to know you as best we can.
Uh, but you're here on a great Sunday
because we are nearing the end of this series
through the book of First Samuel.
In fact, next Sunday will be the last sermon
in this series.
Hint, hint, for those of you who join me in dressing up
to honor that, uh, that's what's coming next week.
But it's been powerful to see
as we've journeyed this whole book,
the the Israel Struggle for a King.
And, and they had to decide whether they were going
to allow, just simply let God be their king,
or if they were gonna ask for a king
like everyone else around them.
And we've seen where they've gone with that,
that they did ask for a king, yet God still worked in spite
of their rebellion.
And he was preparing the way for David
to eventually become the greatest king that Israel ever had
as a type of the Messiah that he was looking forward
to the Messiah to come.
David is a type of that.
As we get into it today though, I want
to tell you about my high school experience with an author,
uh, that some of you might have heard of named, uh,
Shakespeare, I think is his name.
Right. Um, and listen,
I don't remember a whole lot about what I would read.
I, I do remember Cliff's Notes was a big help at the time,
but, uh, I, I do remember something about what he, uh,
when we were assigned to read this in English class, it was
all his works we read were tragedies.
Tragedies. And I give you a couple examples, Romeo
and Juliet, that's a tragedy where these two young people
who are supposedly in love actually end up dying for that.
And it's tragic.
And then you've got Macbeth, which is even more relevant
to this discussed ambition and tyranny
and prideful vengeance ending tragically as well.
Well, the narrative involving King Saul here in one Samuel
is definitely a tragedy
because it describes the terrible events
that befall this main character named Saul.
And it just think about Saul, right?
Such high talent, such high expectations,
yet such pride, such self-sufficiency,
eventually leading to his demise.
And we'll see here at the end of this book.
See, in many ways, Saul was the anti-hero.
David is often not perfectly,
but often presented as this is what you should do.
And Saul is the case of what you are not supposed to do
nearly in its entire life.
And we'll see that today in its full and final form,
and it gets really dark.
Yet in that darkness, my hope is that we today
can see the light of the gospel through it
and the hope we can have in the gospel as well.
And so if you're not already there, turn with me
to First Samuel chapter 28.
First Samuel in the Old Testament, big number 28,
and that's chapter 28.
This is actually the section we skipped last week.
If you were here, we tracked through David's story,
the narrator inserted chapter 28 in the middle,
as a way to contrast Saul with David,
That While David was resetting his relationship
with the Lord and actually ended up able to avoid the battle
that was coming with the Philistines Saul,
you'll see today what he was doing
as he prepared for that same battle.
Look at it now with me. I'm gonna start in verse three.
I'm gonna read the whole chapter,
chapter 28, starting in verse three.
Now, Samuel had died and all Israel had mourned for him
and buried him in Rama his own city.
And Saul had put the mediums
and the necromancers out of the land.
The Philistines assembled and came and encamped at Hunam,
and Saul gathered all Israel and they encamped at Gilboa.
When Saul saw the army of the Philistines, he was afraid.
His heart trembled greatly.
And when Saul inquired of the Lord,
the Lord did not answer him
Either By dreams or by em or by prophets.
Then Saul said to his servants, seek out for me a woman
who is a medium that I may go to her and inquire of her.
His servants said to him, behold,
there's a medium at indoor.
And so Saul disguised himself and put on other garments
and went, he and two men with him.
And they came to the woman by night
and he said, divine for me by a spirit
and bring up for me whomever I shall name to you.
And the woman said to him, surely you know
what Saul has done, how he's cut off the mediums
and Necker answers from the land.
Why then are you laying a trap for my life
to bring about my death?
But Saul swore to her by the Lord, As the Lord lives,
no punishment shall come upon you for this thing.
And he said, then the woman said,
whom shall I bring up for you?
And he said, bring up Samuel for me.
When the woman saw Samuel, she cried out with a loud voice.
And the woman said to Saul, why have you deceived me?
You are Saul. And the king said to her, do not be afraid.
What do you see? The woman said to Saul,
I see a God coming up out of the earth.
He said to her, what's his appearance?
And she said, an old man is coming up.
He's wrapped in a robe.
And Saul knew that it was Samuel,
and he bowed with his face to the ground and paid homage.
Then Samuel said to Saul,
why have you disturbed me by bringing me up?
Saul answered, I'm in great distress
for the Philistines are warring against me,
and God has turned away from me
and answers me no more either by prophets or by dreams.
Therefore, I've summoned you to tell me what I shall do.
And Samuel said, why then do you ask me
since the Lord has turned from you
and become your enemy, the Lord has done to you as he spoke
by me, for the Lord has torn the kingdom out of your hand
and given it to your neighbor, David,
because you did not obey the voice of the Lord,
did not carry out his fierce wrath against Amalek.
Therefore, the Lord has done this thing to you this day.
Moreover, the Lord will give Israel also
with you into the hand of the Philistines, and tomorrow you
and your sons shall be with me, meaning die.
The Lord will give the army Israel also
into the hand of the Philistines.
Then Saul fell at once, full length on the ground, filled
with fear because of the words of Samuel.
There was no strength in him.
He'd eaten nothing all day, all night.
And the woman came to Saul when she saw he was terrified,
she said, behold, your servant has obeyed you.
I've taken my life in my hand.
Listen to what you said to me now,
therefore, you obey your servant.
Let me set a morsel of bread before you
and eat that you should have
strength when you go on your way.
He refused. He said, I will not eat.
But his servants together with a woman urged him.
He listened to their words and he rose from the bed
and sat on the bed and the woman
had a fatten calf in the house.
She killed it, took flour
and needed it baked on lemon bread with it.
She put it before Saul and his servants, and they ate,
and then they rose and went away that night.
So a lot to explain here.
I know we'll get into it a little bit more,
but let's just take first glance, just look at
what we just saw.
Is it not stunning how far
Saul has fallen king, anointed all
of this, and here on the night
before, the most important battle of his life,
this is what he's doing.
That's why it's a tragedy. It's tragic.
So here's what we're gonna do with this passage.
As we see the tragedy of Saul's life,
I wanna use this passage to simply share three principles
from Saul's life and really from the whole book,
but then, then also three applications from his life
and the book as well.
So three principles, then three applications.
And here's the first principle,
really, again, the whole book.
It's that Saul responded
to crisis differently than David did.
Saul responded to crisis differently than David.
We've seen it over and over again, especially right here.
You see it again. Here's the first crisis
that Saul faced here in chapter 28, the first crisis,
right off the bat, verse three, it's that Samuel had died.
Now remember Samuel Heath's named the book, of course, but
but the stabilizing force
that helped transition Israel from the judges to the kings.
This, this voice of God, the mouthpiece of God, the one
who anointed both the kings of Saul
and David, this amazing, powerful figure that was the vessel
of God to the people.
He's now gone. He's dead.
So how would Saul respond to that crisis?
Well, he derailed even further.
He'd already been, now he's even further.
And that's the main point of this passage.
It's Saul's, the all
of chapter 28 is Saul's response to verse six.
Look at what verse six says.
When Saul inquired of the Lord,
the Lord did not answer him.
Dreams are in Prophe.
Those are the ways that God would speak at that time.
But again, the point the Lord did not answer him
all of chapter 28 is Saul's response to that.
And, and really Samuel's death is kind
of just a metaphor here for Saul's relationship with God.
Samuel and Saul had not spoken for months,
if not years at this point.
And now Samuel's completely gone in a way, God
and Saul had not spoken for years.
And Now in a sense, God is
Gone.
He's abandoned Saul. Saul is in the dark.
And so that's the first crisis. How would Saul respond?
He freaks out. The other crisis only added a layer to this,
that the Philistines were right on the border.
They're coming, right? They've amassed for battle.
This whole thing's about to come.
And how would Saul respond to this one?
We saw how he responded to Samuel's death.
How would Saul respond to this?
Verse five, when Saul saw the army of the Philistines,
he was afraid and his heart trembled greatly.
Zero, trust in the Lord, no remembrance
of all that God had done for generation
after generation for his people.
He came through, he defended them, he defeated the enemy.
He completely forgot all of that.
He just looked at his circumstances with utter terror.
The army. What's hopeless?
He was afraid. You add to that
verse 15, what Saul said there, he's like,
I'm in great distress.
The Philistines are warring against me.
God has turned away from me and answers me no more.
Right? He, he understands. He is a desperate man, right?
He is terrified of the army. He knows God's abandoned him.
He, he, he's so afraid
that here in chapter 28, he breaks God's explicit
law against the spirit world.
That's how desperate he is.
God's not speaking the army's right here.
I better go find a way.
I guess I'll use this way, Samuel. I need you.
I gotta find somehow, and he just tries
to figure out an answer.
And he breaks God's law in doing so,
quite the comparison to David, right?
Again, David's not perfect.
We'll see that again in the second Samuel passages in the
fall when we get to that, like, that's, that's clear.
David's not perfect, but David consistently came back
to God when he was confronted over sin.
He, he kept coming back.
He kept returning to his trust in Yahweh.
He said, God, I know you're gonna work this out.
God, I know I strayed from you.
I I need to come back to you.
I know you're gonna work it out. I'm gonna trust you, Saul,
at the complete opposite end of that spectrum.
I don't trust you. I'm gonna do everything against you.
That's what Saul gets to at this point.
He responded to crisis very differently
because something in his heart was very different than
David's second
principle is very similar to that actually.
It's that Saul loved himself
and this world more than he loved God.
Seen it here, right? Chapter 28.
But it's also throughout the whole book, Saul loved himself
and this world more than God.
I mean, Saul was trying to kill David
because he felt threatened.
He thought David's gonna steal my throne.
In fact, God had already said David was gonna be the king,
but Saul was like, no, no, no.
I gotta clinging to this. I gotta hold on
to everything like it's mine.
I, I cherish this so much
because Saul thought he had a better plan
for his life than what God had.
He thought, I have a better plan for Israel.
I have a better plan for the world than
what God has in store.
So I'm gonna take it into my hands instead of trusting God.
See, Saul had forgotten
God's promise all the way back in Deuteronomy six,
when God delivered his people out of slavery in Egypt.
He brought them through the wilderness.
He showed them miracle after miracle, all of these things.
He says, then at the end, he says, I'm gonna bless you
if you obey me, if you keep this covenant,
all of this will be your, all
of this will be a blessing if you, the covenant is, if you
Deuteronomy six, five, love the Lord your God
with all your heart and
with all your soul and with all your might.
That was it. Like if you guys want the blessing, love me
with everything you are,
that was Israel's primary responsibility.
That was Saul's primary responsibility to love God first
and foremost above all else.
But instead, Saul put God to the test
by chasing after all these other gods, including himself
as his God.
And what it did is it kindled God's anger against Saul.
Saul loved himself
and this world more than he loved God.
It reminds me of in the New Testament, there's a story
of Jesus talking to this man who was very rich,
and this young man was moral, upright,
did the right things, and Jesus pushed on the one thing
in his heart that he was unwilling to give up.
It was his wealth.
And he said, you need to give that up to follow me.
And the man walked away from Jesus.
See, Saul loved his stuff, his power, his prestige,
his position, all of that more than he loved Yahweh.
And he lost the kingdom because of it,
because of his rebellion against God.
This is the third principle.
He lost the kingdom because he said, God, I don't want you.
I want to be in control. I think I have a better plan.
My plan is better than yours. That's rebellion against God.
And he lost the kingdom.
You might recall back in earlier chapters in first Samuel,
Samuel confronted Saul when Saul failed
to obey God's command fully remember,
God had commanded Saul to, to go to the Amalekites
and to wipe everything out
because they were opposing God in everything, in every way.
And Saul kept some of 'em like the, the good animals
for sacrifices is what he said, right?
I'm gonna keep this stuff and,
and God, I'm using this for you, right?
I'm supposed to do this this way,
but no, I'm gonna do it my way.
This is what Samuel said to Saul back at
that time, back in chapter 15, if you remember
that chapter 15, this is what Samuel said to Saul.
He said, has the Lord as great delight and burnt offerings
and sacrifices as in obeying the voice of the Lord.
Behold, to obey is better than sacrifice.
To listen to God is better than the fat
of rams, right?
'cause, 'cause Saul said, no, no, I'm gonna keep the good
animals for the sacrifice.
And Samuel's like God doesn't want that.
God wants you. God wants your heart.
God wants you to obey, to listen. That's what he wants.
Now, watch what else he says, Samuel says to Saul,
for rebellion is as the sin of divination
And presumption is as iniquity and idolatry,
because you have rejected the word of the Lord.
He has also rejected you from being king.
And you add verse 28 down there,
the Lord has torn the kingdom of Israel from you this day,
has given it to a neighbor of yours who's better than you.
That is what Samuel said
to Saul all the way back in chapter 15,
when Saul rebelled.
And here in chapter 28,
that message just gets repeated from Samuel to Saul, right?
Saul hears the exact same thing
that God has become your enemy, Saul.
God tore the kingdom away from you in favor of David Saul.
You're in trouble. Which leads us
to finally what we'll see next week.
As spoiler alert, Saul
and his sons die in the battle,
just like God said would
happen again.
Is the story of Saul not a tragedy?
Is it not just so sad to watch as we've been walking
through this for months, we see Saul who has such potential,
such a high stand, he just declines step by step by step
to finally this point here.
E even interestingly, back in chapter 15, Samuel equated
the sin of rebellion with the sin of divination.
Did you see that? To the point now in chapter 28,
Saul actually does the sin of divination.
It wasn't just like it. He actually dabbled in it.
It's a tragedy. And
so the question is, what do we do with it?
What do we learn from this?
Yeah, from this passage, chapter 28, of course.
But really from the whole book, as we trace the narrative
of Saul's life, what do we learn from this?
And so we had the three principles.
We see what God has done and how he's, how he's used this
and how Saul has tracked and they signed.
But but what are the three applications next?
So we saw the principles. Now the three applications we can
glean from this passage.
So here, here's the first one today.
Beware of searching for worldly answers
to spiritual problems.
Beware searching for worldly answers to
spiritual problems.
We need to read carefully when we read God's word,
When we read chapter 28, carefully.
It's interesting how many times this concept of hearing God
listening to God, voice of God comes up in this passage.
'cause think about this. Samuel was God's mouthpiece.
Verse three, he died.
So it's kinda like it stopped in some way.
Verse six, God didn't answer Saul, he says that verse 15,
Saul had seen that.
God stopped answering him.
Verse 16, Samuel said, why do you ask me? Right?
There's all these things about hearing from God.
Verse 17, God had spoken through Samuel
before, but he's not anymore.
In verse 18, Saul didn't obey God's voice.
Like, so there's all this happening here.
Hearing from God seems to be the core issue here.
'cause the, the core issue was not something physical like,
man, that the Philistine Army's coming, or Samuel has died.
The core issue was that God had stopped speaking to Saul.
He doesn't know what to do with that. It was
a spiritual problem at its heart, right?
It wasn't a physical problem of armies or deaths.
It was a spiritual problem in his heart.
Yet instead of getting to that root
and running in repentance, back
to God saying, here's where I am.
I'm, I'm wrong here.
He instead disobeyed further
By heading to this necromancer, this medium, this
spiritual woman.
Now we could go really far down the rabbit hole of that, of
what actually happened here in chapter 28.
And if you go read about it later, you'll find all kinds
of debate and opinions on what actually happened here
with this woman and the spirit and Samuel.
And was it just in Saul's mind?
Was he thinking this way
or was it actually happening that Samuel, we, we don't know.
But what we know for sure is that this is evidence
of how far Saul had fallen spiritually.
Because God's law was abundantly clear that
what he's doing here, what she's doing,
what he's participating in, was forbidden.
It was sinful. There's no question.
It's not like some preference issue
or it's a vague thing in the,
it is absolutely clear in the Old Testament.
It's what pagan nations did.
'cause they didn't have a God who spoke to them.
They're trying to find their way by finding spirits
and spiritual world stuff.
They're trying to, they didn't have a God who spoke.
So they did that. That's what pagan nations did.
It had no place in the people of God.
In fact, the law said mediums
necromancers were to be put to
Death's. Why?
This woman was so afraid, right?
She's like, are you trapping me?
Like you said, the king should know as Saul.
Yet the king said, I'm supposed to be put out of the,
I still make a lot of money
doing this, so I'm still doing it.
But you see this as dangerous, right?
Which is in fact what Saul
apparently believed to begin with.
'cause he's the one who said all
of them be put outta the land.
Yet, in his desperation, what does he do?
He breaks his own prohibition.
He goes and finds this medium, and he sins.
It was actually the final straw with God.
First Chronicles reports it like this about Saul
chapter 10 of one Chronicles says, Saul died
for his breach of faith.
He broke faith with the Lord in
that he did not keep the command of the Lord.
We've already seen that one. And also consulted a medium
seeking guidance.
And here's the kicker. He did not
seek guidance from the Lord.
Therefore, the Lord put him to death
and turned the kingdom over to David, the son of Jesse.
Again, this was a spiritual problem that Saul tried
to use worldly means to answer.
You ever done that before you ever had
something in your soul that's not right,
and you feel like I'm separated from God?
I'm, I'm a little bit, it's a little drifting spiritually,
and, and I'm gonna look for worldly answers to fix it.
I, I have, I'm gonna share
with you a little bit of my battle in this.
This is just because maybe my brain,
like engineering degree, those kind of things.
Maybe this is how I work, but here's the problem.
I'll, I'll feel spiritually dry, sometime
undisciplined, spiritually, just kind
of see 'em drifting away from the Lord a little bit.
And, and instead of what it should be, here's
where my mind will go, drifting undisciplined.
Like, okay, I need a new planner.
Like I, I need a new, I need a new system.
Like I'm gonna write this. I gotta get my to-do
list a calendar, right?
Like, I'm just on discipline.
I gotta figure out a way to order my day better, right?
Like, that's how may be productive, right?
No, like it's a spiritual problem.
Like I, I'm completely missing the point here.
My problem is in here.
It's not about systems and paper and calendars.
None of that's my problem.
What I need is that my love has grown cold.
I need to run back to my father and find hope
and joy in life in abiding in him.
That's my problem. It has nothing to do
with my calendar at all.
It's all about in here the spiritual problem I'm trying
to fix with a worldly means
it's a spiritual problem.
Maybe you don't relate to that one, okay?
Maybe you're dissatisfied with your life
because you have heard over
and over thousands
of different reasons why you should be dissatisfied
with your life because you don't look the right way.
Your relationship's not right,
or you don't have a relationship or,
or your job's less than ideal.
And so you're like, man, I'm dissatisfied.
The world is constantly tossing dis.
Every commercial you watch on TV is
because it's trying to create
dissatisfaction in you in something.
And so that's what you feel.
Yet, instead of turning to God and his word
and abiding in him for satisfaction, we instead turn
to TikTok or to self-help books
or whatever else, thinking, well,
this is gonna be the answer.
Maybe this little 92nd clip will solve all my problems.
And it's worldly means to try
to solve what's really a spiritual problem inside me
that I'm dissatisfied with God, not with my life.
Now, you might get a snippet here and there
because all truth is God's truth.
Like there might be something you
catch, like, yeah, that, that works.
It will not sustain you though,
like a relationship with God Almighty does
beware of searching
for worldly answers to spiritual problems.
Here's the second application from Saul's life.
Similar, it's
that it will get very dark while you are sinning.
It will get very dark
while you are walking down a path of sin.
All of chapter 28 is an illustration of this at here,
at the end of Saul's life.
This is just the capstone, the final step.
It's all about darkness. Did you see that?
He, in verse six, he says, God's not speaking to me.
I, I think God's abandoned me. What does that feel like?
That feels like darkness.
He feels like he's walking around in darkness
because he has no ability to hear from God.
And then he goes to this woman under the cover of darkness
at night, he disguises himself in a dark way
so that no one can see him.
No one knows who he is.
And then the message he received is not a positive one.
It's a very dark message, right?
You have had the kingdom ripped away from you
and you're gonna die tomorrow.
And then at the end, he leaves
still under the cover of darkness.
This chapter 28 is just the final straw.
But this was the trajectory we've
been watching of Saul's life, right?
This has been the whole time he started up here.
He was so anointed and high, all this great things.
He was expected to be this amazing man.
And then he just step by step
by step into the darkness deeper
and deeper from the time he rebelled against God's command,
he went further and further and further into it.
He was trying to hunt and kill David multiple times.
He cast off God's plan, God's law.
Even we saw it here, the final straw, this forbidden woman
that he goes into to, into her house to get her
to tell him something.
He's so desperate. He's trying
to get Samuel to answer for him.
He has no clue what's going on.
He's that far into the darkness.
But that's always the trajectory of sin, isn't it?
Like darkness, sin
doesn't get better, it doesn't get lighter.
The farther you go down that path, that is the trajectory
of sin.
I know, I know.
Sin always promises to make life better.
It promises to make life more pleasurable,
to make life more fulfilling.
We wouldn't sin if it didn't feel good for a while.
We're hedonists at heart, right? You know that.
Like, I'm not gonna do this if it doesn't feel good
or doesn't sustain me for a second, for a while.
I wouldn't do it if it, but it's so sin does, right?
It it, it does.
But, but here's one you might wanna write down.
This is not original to me.
Sin always over promises
and under delivers every single time.
It offers overpromising something
and underdelivering every single time.
The enemy loves the bait and switch game, right?
You know, like you go fishing
and you toss the lure out there,
it sure looks like a nice little worm that
that bass is gonna come up, it's gonna take it,
and it's promising something, sustaining a meal,
whatever it is, what's inside that worm?
A hook. So it tosses the lure
and the listen, the enemy is tossing lures left
and right at us every single day with hooks inside.
So when you bite on it, he sets the hook and he's got you.
It always over promises
and under delivers, it will destroy
sin might feel pleasurable for a season.
It might look appealing.
It might look like this is the right way to go,
but it will only lead
to increasing darkness the further you go in it.
And I know, listen, I've been there.
I know what some
of you right now are feeling when you're walking day
by day in that darkness
and you know, you, you feel like there is no way out.
There's a, there's a sunk cost fallacy
that we feel like,
because I've already gone down a little bit of that path,
I might as well just go all the way.
You've sunk some of the costs already.
Like, well, I've already sinned.
I might as well just keep going in it.
Might as well just keep doing it like that.
If you have already begun to walk down a path of darkness,
you, you get nothing else today.
Hear this, you don't have to keep going down that path.
If you're in the kingdom of God,
There, There is nothing making you
continue that path.
You don't have to listen there.
There's a truth in one Corinthians 10 13.
No temptation has seized you except
what is common to all of us.
But God is faithful him, not let you be tempted beyond
what you can bear, meaning what He strengthen you to handle.
And he will always provide a way out.
Every time you're tempted, there's a way out.
We just have to look for it, and we have to want it.
Sin is pleasurable. You don't want it often,
but there is a way
out in God's power.
There's always a way out. Saul's life is a tragic picture
of having an opportunity
after opportunity to turn back to God, to exit strategy,
his darkness, to just abdicate his throne
and say, David, okay, you're the king.
I'm out. He gets a position.
We don't know how that would've played out, but he never
Did.
He kept walking the path of darkness,
and he destroyed his life and his son's life as a result.
And so, man, it, it's dark.
Saul's life is a picture of darkness
and it's a, a, a darkness that a lot of us
Have Or are walking in right now.
And so here's
My hope is
That in light of how dark sin is
and how dark our path often is, I also want to share
with the third application that has hope
that we can see the gospel very clearly.
Now because of it,
the final application actually looks forward from Saul.
The anti-hero to the true hero is that Jesus experienced
darkness so that we wouldn't have to
Jesus experienced darkness so
that we would not have to anymore.
Now, we don't know if Saul truly was
God's or not, that that's not mine to judge.
I can't see his heart. That's between him and God.
I don't know if he truly is a believer of filled with faith.
I don't know. That's between him and God.
But what we do know very clearly is that Saul persisting
to turn away from God, led to God appearing
to abandon him.
You don't want me anymore. You got it.
Like, that's how God works, right? We, he won't.
Someone who doesn't want God
will not be one of God's people.
God changes his hearts. God makes you want him.
And so Saul persisted, abandoning God,
and so God abandoned him.
And that's every case we've seen over
and over throughout history.
You abandoned God. You say forget you
God, and he a abandons you.
But there's one, There's one massive
case where someone was forsaken
by God in spite of the fact that they never abandoned him
Once. And it
Is the very reason that we
who are in Christ today can have hope, that we will not
and cannot ever experience abandonment by God in our lives.
It's the fact that Jesus went to the cross track with this.
Watch this Jesus, his whole life was lived in light, right?
He said, I am the light of the world.
He's living in light, perfect lifestyle,
perfect communion with his father.
Everything is perfect. He's walking in light every single
moment of his life.
But then think about how dark it got
For him at the end, the night
Before he was crucified. He's in a dark
Garden, and in that he's praying, God,
Take this cup away from me
because I know the darkness that comes with it.
This, the wrath of God poured out on me like
I know that's coming.
And then he's nailed to the cross where three hours
of the day was total darkness over the land.
And in that, he on the cross cries out, my God, my God,
why have you forsaken me?
Think about it.
That was supposed to be us up
There on that cross, right?
That's us. We deserve that.
We deserve to be abandoned by a holy God
because we have rebelled and turned our back over and over
and over against him.
We have said no to him over and over and over.
Yet this is the good news of the gospel, that
because Jesus was willing to endure the darkness
of God's wrath, the darkness of God's abandonment for us,
we can now walk in the light of Jesus forever.
Like we don't have to remain in darkness ever anymore.
Like not just future forever, like today,
because he experienced it for us.
He defeated it for us.
So we can walk in light today, second Corinthians five,
for our sake, he made him who knew no sin
to be sin on our behalf, so that in him,
we might become the righteousness of
God.
Not just righteousness one day, righteousness today,
that you are not darkness believer.
You don't have to walk in darkness believer
he is the light of the world.
He is light in. This is the light that God offers us.
Church, that's what Isaiah said thousands of years ago.
He said, those who walk in great darkness have
seen a great light.
Who's the light? The light is Jesus Christ.
The light is the perfect one who took our place so
that we could be free from the darkness.
We don't have to be chained up by it anymore.
That's great news, isn't it?
Church, like for sinners like you and me.
We need this. We need this.
So I just wanna invite us now
to enter into a spirit of prayer.
As, as you consider, as we consider, as we think, I,
I want us to just acknowledge
what God is doing, rest in what He's doing, and
and really consider what he is doing among us right now.
I'm gonna invite our worship leaders
to come out while we do this,
but just in a spirit of prayer,
I'm gonna ask a couple questions
and, and these are questions that we all need to consider
in light of what God has done today.
And so just humble yourself right now before the Lord.
Ask him to show you first
how you have looked for worldly answers to spiritual things.
How you've trusted the ways of the world
instead of trusting him and his ways.
Have you done that? How?
Just run back to him in that say,
God, forgive me for that.
I've, I've never trusted you for this.
I, I have trusted my own talents and abilities
and resources instead of trusting you.
Forgive me. He wants to
be your stronghold.
Trust him.
Or maybe you really are walking in darkness right now,
and it feels so hopeless.
It feels like you can't ever get out of it.
There's no way out.
I hope you've seen today hope
that you don't have to stay there.
You don't have to find this resigned
spirit to be in the darkness.
You can walk in light the light of Jesus,
the defeater of darkness.
So run to him in faith, in that cry out, say, God,
I need you to rip this darkness outta me to change my heart.
I see that you are the savior and you can free me from this.
God, do it and just cry out to him in that.
Or maybe this one, this is, this was mine.
Maybe you've just become numb
to the glorious grace and mercy of God for you
not do anything too bad.
You're just drifting numb and it doesn't move your spirit.
Just ask him right now.
God, awaken my stir, my affections for you
to see your carrying
of the darkness for my light.
And run to him in that in humble submission.
Enjoy God. Ask him, God, give me, give me a
restore restored joy of your selfish.